- Lion dance is not only for Chinese,
lion dance for the
people who is passionate.
My name is James Liao.
I'm born and brought up in India, Kolkata.
I have been teaching lion
dance and martial art
more than 10 years.
The lion dance is centuries-old tradition
performed for Chinese New
Year and special functions
to bring good luck and prosperities.
The first Chinese came to
Kolkata three hundred years ago.
They used to work for
British to make the ship,
then they worked as tanneries owner,
shoe shops, beauty parlors.
Their migration started mid-eighties,
after nineties, I feel a
lot of people have migrated.
So they came and gone and
there's no other Chinese left,
that's why all my troupe members,
they are all Indians.
(speaks in foreign language)
Flatten, circle, back.
My students are not coming
from a very good income family.
They are struggling to pay the bills.
I give them the lion dance
training classes for free.
We are doing a lot of lion dance shows
and I pay them lots of hongbao
and I think those helps them a lot
for their bills and tuitions
and all kind of stuff.
(clapping)
- (voiceover in foreign language)
(dancers laughing)
- [James] That's my reward
to see them to perform well
and make the crowd happy.
There is something that
they have never seen before
in India.
I'm still using the tradition,
but now I want to mix up
with a little bit of art, a
little bit of entertainment
and comedy to attract more and more crowd.
It's make it more fun to watch.
Three!
- [kids] Three!
- Four!
- [kids] Four!
- One!
- [kids] One!
- Stay there, stay there!
Stay there.
(kids shouting)
I'm going to go about make a future team.
(laughing)
Some people in the Chinese community
is not very happy of what I'm doing,
teaching the Indian kids.
I told them that,
"You should be proud of it,
"that Indians are accepting our culture,
"and they are practicing
it in a serious manner,
"so there is no reason
for you to feel upset."
Any tradition is for everyone,
is not only for the particular race.
Right now, the lion dance is getting
more and more popular in India.
In a few years, there won't be any Chinese
doing the lion dancing,
so we are the first
person to open the market,
and in the future there is going to be
lots of troupe like Malaysia.
- (voiceover in foreign language)